mr. secretary-general world leaders
ambassadors and distinguished delegates
one year ago I stood before you for the
first time in this Grand Hall I
addressed the threats facing our world
and I presented a vision to achieve a
brighter future for all of humanity
today I stand before the United Nations
General Assembly to share the
extraordinary progress we've made in
less than two years my administration
has accomplished more than almost any
administration in the history of our
country America's so true
didn't expect that reaction but that's
okay
America's economy is booming like never
before since my election we've added 10
trillion dollars in wealth the stock
market is at an all-time high in history
and jobless claims are at a 50-year low
african-american Hispanic American and
Asian American unemployment have all
achieved their lowest levels ever
recorded we've added more than 4 million
new jobs including half a million
manufacturing jobs we have past the
biggest tax cuts and reforms in American
history
we've started the construction of a
major border wall and we have greatly
strengthened border security we have
secured record funding for our military
700 billion dollars this year and 716
billion dollars next year our military
will soon be more powerful than it has
ever been before in other words the
United States is stronger safer and a
richer country than it was when I
assumed office less than two years ago
we are standing up for America and for
the American people and we are also
standing up for the world this is great
news for our citizens and for
peace-loving people everywhere we
believe that when nations respect the
rights of their neighbors and defend the
interests of their people they can
better work together to secure the
blessings of safety prosperity and peace
each of us here today is the emissary of
a distinct culture a rich history and a
people bound together by ties of memory
tradition and the values that make our
homelands like nowhere else on earth
that is why America will always choose
independence and cooperation over global
governance control and domination I
honor the right of every nation in this
room to pursue its own customs beliefs
and traditions the United States will
not tell you how to live for work or
worship we only ask that you honor our
sovereignty in return from Warsaw to
Brussels to Tokyo to Singapore it has
been my highest honor to represent the
United States abroad I have forged close
relationships and friendships and strong
partnerships with the leaders of many
nations in this room and our approach
has always yield an incredible change
with support from many countries here
today we have engaged with North Korea
to replace the specter of conflict with
a bold and new push for peace in June I
traveled to Singapore to meet face to
face with North Korea's leader chairman
kim jeong-hoon
we had highly productive conversations
and meetings and we agreed that it was
in both countries interest to pursue the
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
since that meeting we have already seen
a number of encouraging measures that
few could have imagined only a short
time ago the missiles and rockets are no
longer flying in every direction nuclear
testing has stopped some military
facilities are already being dismantled
our hostages have been released and as
promised the remains of our fallen
heroes are being returned home to lay at
rest in American soil
I would like to thank chairman Kim for
his courage and for the steps he has
taken though much work remains to
the sanctions will stay in place until
denuclearization occurs I also want to
thank the many member states who helped
us reach this moment a moment that is
actually far greater than people would
understand far greater but for also
their support and the critical support
that we will all need going forward
special thanks to president moon of
South Korea
Prime Minister Abbey of Japan and
President Xi of China in the Middle East
our new approach is also yielding great
strides and very historic change
following my trip to Saudi Arabia last
year the Gulf countries opened a new
center to target terrorist financing
they are enforcing new sanctions working
with us to identify and track terrorist
networks and taking more responsibility
for fighting terrorism and extremism in
their own region the UAE Saudi Arabia
and Qatar have pledged billions of
dollars to aid the people of Syria and
Yemen and they are pursuing multiple
avenues to ending Yemen's horrible
horrific civil war ultimately it is up
to the nations of the region to decide
what kind of future they want for
themselves and their children for that
reason the United States is working with
the Gulf Cooperation Council Jordan and
Egypt to establish a regional strategic
alliance so that Middle Eastern nations
can advance prosperity stability and
security across their home region thanks
to the United States military and our
partnership with many of your
I am pleased to report that the
bloodthirsty killers known as Isis have
been driven out from the territory they
once held in Iraq and Syria we will
continue to work with friends and allies
to deny radical Islamic terrorists any
funding territory or support or any
means of infiltrating our borders the
ongoing tragedy in Syria is
heartbreaking our shared goals must be
the de-escalation of military conflict
along with a political solution that
honors the will of the Syrian people in
this vein we urge the United Nations LED
peace process be reinvigorated but rest
assured the United States will respond
if chemical weapons are deployed by the
Assad regime
I commend the people of Jordan and other
neighboring countries for hosting
refugees from this very brutal civil war
as we see in Jordan the most
compassionate policy is to place
refugees as close to their homes as
possible to ease their eventual return
to be part of the rebuilding process
this approach also stretches finite
resources to help far more people
increasing the impact of every dollar
spent every solution to the humanitarian
crisis in Syria must also include a
strategy to address the brutal regime
that is fuelled and financed it the
corrupt dictatorship in Iran Iran's
leaders so chaos death and destruction
they do not respect their neighbors or
borders or the sovereign rights of
Nations
instead Iran's leaders plundered the
nation's resources to enrich themselves
and to spread mayhem across the Middle
East and far beyond the Iranian people
are rightly outraged that their leaders
have embezzled billions of dollars from
Iran's treasure seized valuable portions
of the economy and looted the people's
religious endowments all to line their
own pockets and send their proxies to
wage war not good Iran's neighbors have
paid a heavy toll for the region's
agenda of aggression and expansion that
is why so many countries in the Middle
East strongly supported my decision to
withdraw the United States from the
horrible 2015 Iran nuclear deal and
reimpose nuclear sanctions the Iran deal
was a windfall for Iran's leaders in the
years since the deal was reached Iran's
military budget grew nearly 40% the
dictatorship used the funds to build
nuclear capable missiles increase
internal repression finance terrorism
and fund havoc and slaughter in Syria
and Yemen
the United States has launched a
campaign of economic pressure to deny
the regime the funds it needs to advance
its bloody agenda last month we began
reimposing hard-hitting nuclear
sanctions that have been lifted under
the Iran deal additional sanctions will
resume November 5th
and war will follow and we are working
with countries that import Iranian crude
oil to cut their purchases substantially
we cannot allow the world's leading
sponsor of terrorism to possess the
planet's most dangerous weapons we
cannot allow a regime that chants death
to America and that threatens Israel
with annihilation to possess the means
to deliver a nuclear warhead to any city
on earth just can't do it we ask all
nations to isolate Iran regime as long
as its aggression continues and we ask
all nations to support or rance people
as they struggle to reclaim their
religious and righteous destiny this
year we also took another significant
step forward in the Middle East in
recognition of every sovereign state to
determine its own capital I move the US
Embassy in Israel to Jerusalem the
United States is committed to a future
of peace and stability in the region
including peace between the Israelis and
the Palestinians that aim is advanced
not harmed by acknowledging the obvious
facts America's policy of principle
realism
means we will not be held hostage to all
dogmas discredited ideologies and
so-called experts who have been proven
wrong over the years time and time again
this is true not only in matters of
peace what it matters of prosperity we
believe that trade must be fair and
reciprocal
the United States will not be taken
advantage of any longer for decades the
United States opened its economy the
largest by far on earth with few
conditions we allowed foreign goods from
all over the world to flow freely across
our borders yet other countries did not
grant us fair and reciprocal access to
their markets in return even worse some
countries abused their openness to dump
their products subsidize their goods
target our industries and manipulate
their currencies to gain unfair
advantage over our country as a result
our trade deficit ballooned to nearly
800 billion dollars a year for this
reason we are systematically
renegotiating broken and bad trade deals
last month we announced a groundbreaking
us-mexico trade agreement and just
yesterday I stood with President moon to
announce the successful completion of
the brand-new u.s. Korea trade deal and
this is just the beginning
many nations in this hall will agree
that the world trading system is in dire
need of change for example countries
were admitted to the World Trade
Organization that violate every single
principle on which the organization is
based while the United States and many
other nations play by the rules these
countries use government-run Industrial
Planning and state-owned enterprises to
rig the system in their favor
they engage in relentless product
dumping forced
technology transfer and the theft of
intellectual property the United States
lost over three million manufacturing
jobs nearly a quarter of all steel jobs
and sixty thousand factories after China
joined the WTO and we have racked up 13
trillion dollars in trade deficits over
the last two decades but those days are
over we will no longer tolerate such
abuse we will not allow our workers to
be victimized our companies to be
cheated and our wealth to be plundered
and transferred America will never
apologize for protecting its citizens
the United States has just announced
tariffs on another 200 billion dollars
in Chinese made goods for a total so far
of 250 billion dollars I have great
respect and affection from my friend
President Xi but I've made clear our
trade imbalance is just not acceptable
China's market distortions and the way
they deal cannot be tolerated as my
administration has demonstrated America
will always act in our national
interests I spoke before this body last
year and warned that the UN Human Rights
Council had become a grave embarrassment
to this institution shielding egregious
human rights abusers while bashing
America and its many friends our
ambassador to the United Nations nikki
Haley laid out a clear agenda for reform
but despite reported and repeated
warnings no action at all was taken so
the United States took the only
responsible course we withdrew from the
Human Rights Council and we will not
return until real reform is enacted for
similar reasons the United States will
provide no support and recognition to
the International Criminal Court as far
as America is concerned the ICC has no
jurisdiction no legitimacy and no
authority the icc claims near universal
jurisdiction over the citizens of every
country violating all principles of
justice fairness and due process we will
never surrender America sovereignty to
an unelected unaccountable global
bureaucracy America is governed by
Americans we reject the ideology of
globalism and we embrace the doctrine of
patriotism around the world responsible
nations must defend against threats to
sovereignty not just from global
governments but also from other new
forms of coercion and domination in
America we believe strongly in energy
security for ourselves and for our
allies we have become the largest energy
producer anywhere on the face of the
earth the United States stands ready to
export our abundant affordable supply of
oil clean coal and natural gas OPEC and
OPEC nations are as usual ripping off
the rest of the world and I don't like
it
nobody should like it we defend many of
these nations for nothing and then they
take advantage of us by giving us high
oil prices not good we want them to stop
raising prices we want them to start
lowering prices and they must contribute
substantially to military protection
from now on we are not going to put up
with it these horrible prices much
longer reliance on a single foreign
supplier can leave a nation vulnerable
to extortion and intimidation that is
why we congratulate European states such
as Poland for leading the construction
of a Baltic pipeline so that nations are
not dependent on Russia to meet their
energy needs Germany will become totally
dependent on Russian energy if it does
not immediately change course here in
the Western Hemisphere we are committed
to maintaining our independence from the
encroachment of expansionist foreign
powers it has been the formal policy of
our countries since President Monroe
that we reject the interference of
foreign nations in this Hemisphere and
in our own affairs the United States has
recently strengthened our laws to better
screen foreign investments in our
country for national security threats
and we welcome cooperation with
countries in this region and around the
world that wish to do the same you need
to do it for your own protection the
United States is also working with
partners in Latin America to confront
threats to sovereignty from
uncontrolled migration tolerance for
human struggling and you've been
smuggling and trafficking is not humane
it's a horrible thing that's going on at
levels that nobody has ever seen before
it's very very cruel illegal immigration
funds criminal networks ruthless gangs
and the flow of deadly drugs illegal
immigration exploits vulnerable
populations hurts hard-working citizens
and has produced a vicious cycle of
crime violence and poverty only by
upholding national borders destroying
criminal gangs can we break this cycle
and establish a real foundation for
prosperity we recognize the right of
every nation in this room to set its own
immigration policy in accordance with
its national interests just as we ask
other countries to respect our own right
to do the same which we are doing that
is one reason the United States will not
participate in the new global compact on
migration migration should not be
governed by an international body
unaccountable to our own citizens
ultimately the only long-term solution
to the migration crisis is to help
people build more hopeful futures in
their home countries make their
countries great again currently we are
witnessing a human tragedy as an example
in Venezuela more than two million
people have fled the anguish inflicted
by the socialist Maduro regime and its
Cuban sponsors
not long ago Venezuela was one of the
richest countries on earth today
socialism has bankrupted the oil-rich
nation and driven its people into abject
poverty virtually everywhere socialism
or communism has been tried it has
produced suffering corruption and decay
socialism's thirst for power leads to
expansion incursion and oppression all
nations of the world should resist
socialism and the misery that it brings
to everyone in that spirit we ask the
nations gathered here to join us in
calling for the restoration of democracy
in Venezuela today we are announcing
additional sanctions against the
repressive regime targeting murderers
inner circle and close advisers we are
grateful for all of the work the united
nations does around the world to help
people build better lives for themselves
and their families the United States is
the world's largest giver in the world
by far a foreign aid but few give
anything to us that is why we are taking
a hard look at US foreign assistance
that will be headed up by Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo we will examine what
is working what is not working and
whether the countries who receive our
dollars and our protection also have our
interests at heart
moving forward we are only going to give
foreign aid to those who respect us and
frankly are our friends and we expect
other countries to pay their fair share
for the cost of their defense the United
States is committed to making the United
Nations more effective and accountable I
have said many times that the United
Nations has unlimited potential as part
of our reform effort I have told our
negotiators that the United States will
not pay more than 25% of the UN
peacekeeping budget this will encourage
other countries to step up get involved
and also share in this very large burden
and we are working to shift more of our
funding from assessed contributions to
voluntary so that we can target American
resources to the programs with the best
record of success only when each of us
does our part and contributes our share
can we realize the UN's highest
aspirations we must pursue peace without
fear hope without despair and security
without apology looking around this hall
where so much history has transpired we
think of the many before us who have
come here to address the challenges of
their nations and of their times and our
thoughts turned to the same question
that ran through all their speeches and
resolutions through every word and every
hope it is the question of what kind of
world will we leave for our children and
what kind of nations they will inherit
the dreams that fill this hall today are
as diverse as the people who have stood
at this podium and as varied as the
country
is represented right here in this body
are it really is something it really is
great great history there is India a
free society over a billion people
successfully lifting countless millions
out of poverty and into the middle class
there is Saudi Arabia where King Salman
and the crown prince are pursuing bold
new reforms there is Israel proudly
celebrating its 70th anniversary as a
thriving democracy in the Holy Land in
Poland the great people are standing up
for their independence their security
and their sovereignty many countries are
pursuing their own unique visions
building their own hopeful futures and
chasing their own wonderful dreams of
Destiny of legacy and of a home the
whole world is richer humanity is better
because of this beautiful constellation
of nations each very special each very
unique and each shining brightly in its
part of the world in each one we see
awesome promise of a people bound
together by a shared past and working
toward a common future as for Americans
we know what kind of future we want for
ourselves we know what kind of a nation
America must always be in America we
believe in the majesty of freedom and
the dignity of the individual we believe
in self-government and the rule of law
and we prized the culture that sustains
our Liberty a culture built on strong
families deep faith and fierce
independence
we celebrate our heroes we treasure our
traditions and above all we love our
country inside everyone in this great
chamber today and everyone listening all
around the globe there is the heart of a
patriot that feels the same powerful
love for urination the same intense
loyalty to your homeland the passion
that burns in the hearts of patriots and
the souls of Nations has inspired reform
and revolution sacrifice and
selflessness scientific breakthroughs
and magnificent works of art our task is
not to erase it but to embrace it to
build with it to draw on its ancient
wisdom and to find within it the will to
make our nations greater a region safer
and the world better to unleash this
incredible potential in our people we
must defend the foundations that make it
all possible sovereign and independent
nations are the only vehicle where
freedom has ever survived democracy has
ever endured where peace has ever
prospered and so we must protect our
sovereignty and our cherished
independence above all when we do we
will find new avenues for cooperation
unfolding before us we will find new
passion for peacemaking rising within us
we will find new purpose new resolve and
new spirit flourishing all around us and
making this a more beautiful world in
which to live
so together let us choose a future of
patriotism prosperity and pride
let us choose peace and freedom over
domination and defeat and let us come
here to this place to stand for our
people and their nations forever strong
forever sovereign forever just and
forever thankful for the Grace and the
goodness and the glory of God
thank you god bless you and God bless
the nations of the world thank you very
much
[Applause]